hey what's up everybody welcome back to  the cosmic wonder I'm your host Warren  Thompson and the Spider-Man no way home  Extended Cut is now out it features 11  minutes of new footage not shown in the  original copy you can pick it up  digitally and you can pick it up  physically as well and with this like I  said comes the 11 minutes of new footage  some of this footage includes Matt  Murdock more scenes of Matt Murdoch  being Happy's lawyer and even though  it's a brief scene Charlie Cox  absolutely kills it as Matt Murdock of  course like always here's the scene  my client has nothing to do with the  missing technology he's a law-abiding  citizen he has nothing to hide that's  right  Mr Hogan is there something wrong  so like I said you can pick up the  extended version now let me know what  you think about this scene don't forget  to like the video and subscribe so you  don't miss out on any of the latest MCU  news and as always thank you all so much  for watching woof woof